islamic terrorists killed hundreds in
sri lanka on easter sunday
but what's key beyond the horror was
that the targeted country was aware of
the threat
and this nugget from usa today quote the
country's prime minister
and his cabinet were unaware of the
intelligence
until after the attacks due to political
dysfunction political dysfunction which
is really code for
deadly incompetence and taking your eye
off the ball
it's something to remember as our media
invites us to chase phantoms of
of their own making lost in fever dreams
over collusion obstruction impeachment
hate hoaxes stormy and avenatti
is that real evil still stalks this
planet
and terror is liquid always seeking the
path of least resistance
and that path is often carved by our own
distractions
sparked by those who see politics as far
more important than our safety
which is why terror couldn't compete
with the mueller report even on
easter nothing matters except winning
that news cycle
but hey it happened far away and in
america it's a peaceful time
but only because there are people you
don't know making sure
it's still peaceful until one day when
terror strikes us
at home as it has before we can't forget
that america is terror target number one
and that our number one priority isn't
impeachment but security
our borders grid landmarks water food
supply
everything's up for grabs in a time
where terror has smart phones too
and when something big finally strikes
winning a news cycle looks more than
petty
it's downright dangerous um
uh emily we've talked about this before
al qaeda can
come and go isis can be disappeared but
there will always be
an ideology and an ideology will always
give birth to something new
i think i agree and we've also talked
about it in the context of
that there needs to be some type of
detailed and plan leveled
so that the global messaging that's
happening with islamic terrorism and
those those kind of fundamentalists
we need to address that and i agree with
you that when you
hoard information and when you have
political infighting that prevents you
from
sharing that information that costs
lives and we are on a dangerous
trajectory as well not to be a
fear-monger but we are as well if this
if this is the ball
that some people are focused on it
should be security for
it should be security first 100 percent
um
but i think yes that the the messaging
is important because that's traveling
around the world
dana did uh i guess say two weeks
advanced warning um
did they not take it seriously or was it
just something that
that just got lost they'll have to find
out i mean but what a way to figure it
out afterwards
yeah um secretary pompeo was quite uh
gracious today actually to the sri
lankan saying that we will help we will
provide all this
but we have been helping and we help all
of these countries
and maybe they don't get enough for as
foreign as they would like but
but they have to do something for us too
they have to be willing
to share the information with each other
or at least with us right because
i was just look i got this statistic
today from the brain room since
2012 23 177 christians have been killed
for faith-related reasons
23 000. that is is abhorrent
it is unacceptable and if we are going
to provide aid
and we're going to provide intelligence
services we're going to fight sharing
maybe
military gear whatever it is that they
need the least they could do
is pass it up the chain that there was
going to be an attack it could have been
prevented
one or the eight coordinated detonations
uh this is a group that
we've never heard of but it's kind of
the same thing
right i mean it just mutates changes
evolves
gets better right so this is the
argument that we have you know
before i start that let me just say i so
they're the kids that died there's a kid
a fifth grader from st um several
friends in dc
uh there were three of the four children
of
a danish billionaire right who's the
biggest landowner
in britain and i just can't imagine the
depths of his sadness
uh japanese people were killed so this
was a worldwide event in that sense it
touched us all
and i think it's important to also keep
in mind and we see it here in the u.s
more security on our churches in the
aftermath
of this and there were some suspicions
going back to notre dame and right in
paris
luckily apparently that's just been that
was an accident but i would say this
when you hear people say oh isis is
defeated i worry about it
what i worry because people might think
well then we don't have a threat but we
do have a threat
we have a threat as you described it i
think you said you know water goes
wherever there's an opening right so
what we see is that this ideology now
shifts and we never heard of this group
all of a sudden here they pop up and
they're bombing a church in
sri lanka and they're going after
christians so to me this is a
generational fight the ideology
unfortunately is not defeated and we as
americans cannot lose sight
of the fact that we're in an ongoing
fight and when the president votes for
whatever reason that
isis is defeated don't be fooled we've
got to keep up
not only the attention but the fight and
with regard to the intelligence we know
there are all sorts of arguments about
did we know what was coming on 9 11 and
uh
you know what you can blame me you can
say they're incompetent they're you know
they're not the u.s government not u.s
intelligence not israeli intelligence
they're not british
but the fact is the people responsible
of the terrorists
well right can i clarify that though i
mean because after 9 11 is when we took
down the wall between intelligence
and law enforcement that made a big
difference then we stepped up efforts
all around the world to make sure that
those governments where you knew there
were hot spots would have what they
needed in order to
share to have the information to have
the equipment that they needed we have
we learned a lesson
correct from 911 and if we're going to
help these countries the least they can
do
is they had the information they just
didn't pass it on correct
but so i mean i think that we have made
changes and we have adapted post 911
but i just don't like the idea that we
would say well it's their failure their
fingerprint people did that to us i
didn't like it i didn't think it was
fair to us to our government
uh i think the terrorists are the ones
who should be held responsible
uh so jesse we've seen different
responses to this some some are pretty
odd
yeah uh would you care to uh pick your f
pick the ones that disgust you most or
well i have the washington post right
here and it's just kind of disgusting
christianity under attack sri lanka
church bombing
stoke far right anger in the west
and it's a whole article not about
editorializing about
radical islam murdering people it's it's
editorializing and saying oh
christians are upset that churches are
being bombed
and they're making christians and
conservatives out
to be the villains for reacting to
terrorist attacks
look at some of the leading democrats
how they characterized it
they didn't use christians they didn't
say a lot of
churches they actually said easter
worshipers
were under attack now you don't say you
don't call muslims
ramadan worshipers you don't call jews
passover worshipers
it's a made-up phrase and i think why do
they make up phrases like this
and this is one of the reasons why
people don't trust liberals because
they're not in touch with reality they
do this because
they're pandering to muslims because a
lot of liberals
feel that they are so obsessed with how
other people think about them
and if they're thought of to be
insensitive that drives them crazy
and second of all they think their own
rhetoric causes
islamic extremism remember blame america
first
they think islamophobia causes radical
islam so they do whatever they
can to sanitize it now buzzfeed actually
came out
one of their editors and said wow
president trump
imagine how outraged he'd be if whites
were the victims of the sri lanka attack
and i just found that completely
despicable
to play the race card after a terrorist
attack that's what they did in katrina
remember bush oh he would have acted
faster if there were
white victims in louisiana and when i
step back and think about conservatives
are pretty colorblind
when it comes to life they don't talk
about the different races of babies in
the wombs they want to protect
all life and it's a lot of conservatives
in the media
who talk about stopping the carnage in
the south side of chicago so i think
it's really unfair
when the media always no matter who does
it if it's a white perpetrator muslim
perpetrator hispanic perpetrator
they they just take the violence and
they try to turn it against
the president or his supporters and i
think it's really it's shameful
all right